en el último vídeo llegamos tan lejos
como pudimos tratando de encontrar la
fórmula para el área del copo de nieve
de coche este ya dijimos tiene un
perímetro infinito pero aseguramos que
tiene una área finita y esperemos
encontrar ese valor vamos a hacer todo
lo que está en nuestras manos para
simplificar esta cosa de acá arriba muy
bien así que esto es por lo que vamos a
empezar vamos a centrarnos en esto que
hemos puesto entre paréntesis y vamos a
tratar de encontrar un valor para esta
serie geométrica infinita muy bien así
que vamos a reescribir lo como 3 x 4
novenos muy bien más 4 novenos al
cuadrado más 4 novenos al cubo más
perdón al cubo más todos los demás
términos de aquí hasta el infinito lo
que estamos sumando son todas las
potencias de cuatro novenos y por suerte
como ya dijimos es una serie geométrica
en fin
vamos a encontrar la forma de hacer el
cálculo de esta serie muy bien y bueno
vamos a hacerlo en esta ocasión para
para el caso particular de cuatro
novenos así que vamos a llamarle ese a
esta suma a la suma s le vamos a llamar
a la suma de todas las potencias de
cuatro novenos empezando por cuatro
novenos más cuatro novenos al cuadrado
más cuatro novenos al cubo más todos los
demás términos
digamos ahora que vamos a multiplicar a
s por 4 novenos sale ok entonces si
multiplicamos a s por 4 novenos del lado
izquierdo como nos queda bueno del lado
izquierdo queda 4 novenos por s y del
lado derecho vamos a tener la
multiplicación de todos esos términos
por 4 novenos ok que vamos a obtener
aquí pues vamos a obtener 4 novenos al
cuadrado si multiplicamos a 4 novenos
ahora del segundo término vamos a tener
4 novenos al cubo y eso lo vamos sumando
de aquí hasta el infinito ahora esto es
interesante cuando multiplicamos a 4
novenos por eso en realidad obtenemos
toda la serie de los otros números
excepto por el primer término
esta es la magia de las series
geométricas y qué es lo que vamos a
utilizar para poder llegar al resultado
ok entonces vamos a restar estas dos dos
series y si son expresiones iguales
entonces tendremos simplemente que
restar la rosa de la verde del lado
izquierdo que tenemos tenemos ese menos
cuatro novenos de ese déjenme ponerlo
con estos colores no mejor regresemos al
al rosa tenemos cuatro novenos de ese y
esto a que va a ser igual bueno si se
dan cuenta cuatro novenos al cuadrado se
va o se cancela con el de abajo cuatro
novenos al cubo y así se cancelan todos
los términos hasta el infinito así que
del lado derecho simplemente nos quedó
el primer término que es cuatro novenos
muy bien ahora lo que es del lado
izquierdo vamos a tener que agrupar lo
que incluye a las eses aquí tenemos
nueve novenos de ese que es uno menos
cuatro novenos de ese en ese sentido si
hacemos la resta simplemente nos va a
quedar sin
de ese va a ser igual a cuatro novenos
resolviendo la ecuación para ese ahora
tenemos que si multiplicamos de ambos
lados por nueve quintos
por nueve quintos multiplicamos ya ambos
lados del lado izquierdo se cancelan y
del lado derecho simplemente nos va a
quedar cuatro quintos ahora eso es
sensacional porque entonces toda esta
suma infinita simplemente vale cuatro
quintos así que todo lo que dejamos en
este paréntesis va a equivaler a tres
por cuatro quintos todo esto de este
paréntesis va a equivaler a 12 que es 3
por 4 sobre 5
fácil muy bien ahora vamos a nuestra
expresión original para que no perdamos
la línea de qué es lo que estamos
haciendo
teníamos raíz de 3 por s cuadrada entre
16 x y ahora tenemos este 4 que estaba
aquí más todo lo que valía este
paréntesis que al simplificar lo nos
quedó 12 quintos
ahora
si sumamos estos dos este 4 lo podemos
escribir como 20 quintos 20 quintos para
que podamos hacer la suma de las
fracciones ok ahora si sumamos esto en
realidad nos queda que este paréntesis
déjenme escribirlo por acá abajo todo
este paréntesis en realidad vale 32
quintos
esto esto ya está bastante emocionante
porque estamos encontrando el área de
algo que tenía un perímetro infinito así
que esto si seguimos con las cuentas va
a ser raíz de 3 por s cuadrada sobre 16
que multiplica a 32 sobre 5
muy bien ahora vamos a dividir 32 es de
este numerador por el 16 y aquí
simplemente nos queda 12 y eso
simplemente ya nos queda el área del
copo de nieve de coche donde empezamos
con un triángulo equilátero de medida de
cada uno de sus lados s
así fue como empezamos la construcción
de nuestro copo de nieve y eso va a ser
simplemente su área dos veces la raíz de
3 2 veces la raíz de 3 por s al cuadrado
sobre bueno si ya usamos el 2 raíz de 3
y ese cuadrado sólo nos falta poner en
el denominador un 5 ahora por ejemplo si
hubiéramos empezado con un triángulo
equilátero de longitud de cada uno de
sus lados 1 entonces el área de esta
cosa loca que tiene un perímetro
infinito sería simplemente dos veces la
raíz de 3 sobre 5 de cualquier forma
esto es algo sensacional